going back to the description of my
today's lesson it's going to be on
judgment call because in chess sometimes
there are confusing positions where
um
you may um
you may have a choice between two or
more moves that look uh equally good
[Music]
and
i would like to introduce you guys to
my way of
making a decision when i'm presented
with when i'm presented with a choice uh
between two equally good looking options
so i have i have
two of my games here to show you
um
what goes into my
decision-making process whenever i'm
presented with
a situation just like in this game so
this this is my game from
uh from the spice cup open
uh in 2020
i i was playing remastered um
tightest stream of wishes
i'm playing with wet pieces and this is
why we're seeing this from black's
perspective and yeah this in this
position my opponent played queen a1 uh
do keep in mind that uh at this point my
opponent this is obviously a classical
game and my opponent here
had uh approximately three minutes left
on his clock while i had over 20 minutes
which means that i was in a uh in a
great spot time wise
and
let's just take a look at this position
and see what's what's going on so at
this point i'm i'm clearly upon i have
five
versus whites four pawns
uh
uh every other material seems to be
equal so i have two knights in the queen
white has queen knight and bishop
but if you do notice what what is
happening here is that white is clearly
attacking my pawn on a7 and even though
right now it may seem that i can just
eat the knight for free right since i
have two attackers against the knight
versus single defender and bishop on e5
i'm actually going to be losing the snap
back by force because white can simply
take my phone with a check
now
if my king goes
um
back there obviously i lose control over
the overnight knight on f6 and and loses
right away as a result
um but if my king goes to e6
now we can let me perform a skewer by
attacking my king from either b6 or a6
and and when they're basically going to
win my knight um
in a very similar manner
so
as soon as i lose the knight my material
advantage will be gone and my king will
still be kind of sort of in danger
obviously
this does not look like a good option
and hence uh i need to be
kind of thinking about how to avoid
losing the pawn on a7 if any of you guys
in the chat i want to take a minute
and think about potential ways of
avoiding
the loss of the pawn on a7
what comes to your mind here
i'm going to give you guys a couple of
minutes and then proceed
onto the explanation
the a4 mages meshes 57 very nice queen
a4 as you guys may notice there is no
way to directly defend the pawn on a7
right so there's no piece and black's
position can directly defend it we can
block that time we're playing with a4
this is the move that was made in the
game
um but
is there any other way right so this is
this is a blocking move right queen to
a4 it's it's blocking the attack it's
offering the queen trade what happens if
what happens if white takes
takes up in a trade well
because white snap is still hanging
right technically white and white stand
is still under attack but imagine why it
takes a minute on h7 but unfortunately
in this case because white accepted the
trade my phone
has become a passport on the a file and
can no longer be stopped by any of the
white pieces and this is why obviously
accepting the trade is or not is but
would would have been a fatal mistake
for white
so they didn't they played queen to e1
but even here at this point right i was
presented with it with a choice
actually
even in the original position the idea
is that i was i was kind of trying to
make you
make you find is is to play queen d1 but
actually
when the one here forces a trade of
queens
was a very similar idea to create myself
a bunch of past fonts
that can then be used to you know to
promote
how to be the queens
for hopefully
maybe it won't work but who knows so
here queen d1 would be even more
effective because of the queen d1 white
cannot avoid the trade right where it
has to accept the trading d1 and this
way if you guys notice i am going to be
losing the piece right so just like in
previous position where
white accepted the trade on a4 right
the in this case what can also take
minus an h7 basically for free so this
way
i'm going to find myself in this spot
where i'm down a piece but take a look
at my pawns this endgame is very very
unclear and it's really really hard to
calculate
without using the help of the computer
i'm going to tell you guys it was with a
very very precise defense white can
indeed survive here so it's not about
whether white can win this position or
not white is trying to survive because
in the end game typically what happens
is that the value of the pieces of the
white pieces that is is evaluated and
this is why you see for example end
games such as two white pieces versus a
rook the white pieces would typically be
struggling against rogue because will
become
way more in child than the pieces right
in this case the value of the white
pieces are the value of the white pieces
is devaluated due to the fact that my
pawns are
so
so advanced already and they basically
require no close to no help oops i wish
my drawing skills were better so my
pawns were very close to no help um
to keep going forward and this is why
it is really really difficult for white
to take a good advantage of their extra
piece because they have to immediately
go back or back off and try to stop my
pawns from promoting and
unsurprisingly so the only move for
white here to not lose the game
immediately is to play
d5 which ensures
the help of the bishop so this way white
gives back
there by gives me the pawn and if you
notice right now this position is in
full material balance because fight has
an extra piece well i have three pawns
for it um but thanks to the bishop on e5
it seems it appears that white's going
to be just on time and stopping my
phones from promoting but do remember
when i was talking about the original
position i said that in this case white
has
almost no time on their clock meaning
that they will have a very because they
will have
almost no time to think about their
moves and if i played queen a4 and if
you follow my my decision during the
game which wasn't to play queen d1 right
because i thought to myself that if i go
into an end game this makes it easier
for my opponent to navigate because well
the fewer the amount of pieces in the
board the easier it is to navigate
because you don't have to calculate as
much but what i didn't take into account
is the fact
that
if i avoid the end game which i did by
playing latex f6
queen takes e3 i didn't really realize
how powerful
white's counter attack will be on the
king's side against my
my king and my knight so
this position
surprising to my big surprise look after
the game i announced this position and
realized that i simply cannot avoid
losing back my sound material or
stopping white from
from getting a perpetual check of some
kind so let me show you guys how the
game ended i played windy one so in this
case once again since i'm not material
my um
my goal is to trade
as many pieces as i possibly can because
both white queen and white bishop are so
annoying ideal case scenario would be
for me to trade both of them and go into
a pawn end game where i'm upon so i
played queen d3
unfortunately
this runs into a very specific
issue and that issue is queen to g5
so during the game i was i thought to
myself that oh but maybe i can just play
quinn f5 here
right so this move would offer an
immediate trade
offer an immediate trade of queens while
also defending the mf6 at the same time
however once again there is a problem
with this please take a minute
and tell me
what is the issue with this move
which takes up six may chess is saving
the day yes correct bishop takes f6
forces a trade of the trade of white
pieces and this way i'm gonna lose one
of the pawns back this is not the end of
the world i can actually win
the pawn right back by force by playing
queen f4 check
and then playing queen c1
like this would be a double attack
against the king and the pawn
white has no other way other than to
play kh2
then i would take and in this case we
have transposed into a queen end game
up upon unfortunately due to uh
forced nature of this endgame my game
will find itself in a situation where it
cannot avoid perpetual checks white can
just start checking and if i'm not
careful enough i mean i may even get
myself into a big trouble by blundering
checkmates such as this one
uh this doesn't have to happen i can
just go right back to where i came from
and the again would end in a draw
because my king essentially cannot run
anywhere
from the checks
so this is the problem and this is what
a this is the idea that they kind of
missed out in the game i did not or i i
underestimated white's counter attack
against my king and i let
the queen get even more active by
playing 87 so now i cannot stop the
queen from reaching e7 square which
begins series of of checks that
unfortunately i cannot avoid in the long
run so i can avoid the checks up until
this point but here after white checks
me from e3 to keep avoiding checks i
need to make a decision of whether i
want to play g5 or not if i don't play
g5 and simply go back to where it came
from then the check will will go on and
the game
will likely end the draw because no side
is making progress so i had to play g5
and then to my big surprise i realized
that
even though i did manage to avoid the
checks my pieces are all tied up tied
down right because any
anytime i try to move anything the white
queen will just go behind behind the
lines and start checking me again
uh result 87 hello there good to see you
we are i'm doing a lecture on
um
uh
it's it's a decision decision-making
lecture
that's it's about judgment call between
between the two equally good options
so as you guys can tell at this point
the game is pretty much
uh drawn
so checks persisted and and eventually
eventually we agreed on a draw so
the idea of this um of this particular
example is that sometimes
what may seem like a like a smart
decision
is not a correct decision in the long
run because
queen d1 in this case
would be a smarter option right because
even though we are going an end game
this is a very very tough end game for
white not only because white is why this
has almost no time but also because this
is a very unclear situation right this
is there is material imbalance
in an end game
while i have
three connected past pawns right
connected past pawns
on their own is already a very big
deal in the end games but in this case
my knight will be will be helping them
out by supporting them from behind so
this is this is a kind of judgment code
that's really hard to make unless
uh unless you can you can calculate
everything perfectly and because i was
also
um
kind of running short in time i decided
to go to i decided against this even
though practically speaking there is
close to no risk for me in this case and
uh white is the only one who can lose
so this was this was the first example
um
off we go to the second one
it worked right no
yes
okay second example
i like this this one a lot because um
this was uh a game i played against my
um my good friend ray robson
and uh we played this game in sinful
spring classic tournament which is about
to happen and in less than a month
that's i'm gonna be playing in basically
the same tournament in approximately
three weeks and ray will be playing
there as well so we will have a we'll
have a
we'll have another shot of playing each
other um this game was played in 2019 so
it's been three years since then
and uh
and yeah um
at this point
it's obviously back to moving once again
i'm playing with back pieces here and um
i have um a very clearly defined issue
at this point or at least it is very
clearly defined for me
um and in this case if you guys notice
what most of voice pieces are already
out and the only two pieces that they
kind of still need developing
are are the two rooks but they it kind
of it is kind of clear where the white
looks are going to go right on in both
of the open files while in my case i
still have right i still have my queen
side not completely decided so with this
in mind i believe a very logical looking
move would be
something like
rezan says knight c6 i i think 96 is
definitely definitely is a move but i um
during the game i i did consider an x6
the only reason for why i decided
against it is because it creates me
creates me weakness right of weakness on
c6 c6 pawn um becomes weak and if white
simply doubles the rooks on the c file
like so
it will be a little bit annoying for me
to uh to do to do something about the c6
phone right the c6 phone is a pawn that
requires protection all the time and yes
i see that i do see a very a very good
good
move in the chat j robert gr
pointed out that 97 is just a better
version of 96 it accomplishes the same
thing it offers an even trade um
but at the same time if if the nitrate
does happen
we are not creating ourselves any any
more weaknesses in fact we have a
perfect not perfect symmetry if if black
queen and bishop were swapped places we
would have perfect symmetry but i mean
this is i would say this this also can
this can also be considered a
symmetrical position
it's pretty close
um
well
in in symmetrical positions for this one
i believe it it would be very hard for
either side to uh to make any kind of
progress so uh definitely would be you
know would be a would be a good
candidate to
you know if i wanted if i wanted the
game to conclude
in a peaceful result
but but i had other ideas so in this
case right you may think okay so
this position does not seem like
anything black can
possibly play for a win because well why
it's ahead on development and black is
the one who is currently experiencing uh
an issue an issue of where to develop
the remaining pieces
um however there is a way right so
knight d7 is a is an obvious
and good option
right this option is good because it
allows me to simply get an equal
position and play a normal game with no
complications
but
right so i obviously did see 97 during
the game but i also i also saw a
different kind of move a move that
may not be
as peaceful as 97
but it
it creates
an opportunity for my opponent to go
wrong or to or not i wouldn't say that
it was it created an opportunity for
white to go wrong but it definitely
created a more dynamic position in the
long run so if you guys think about how
to combine
the goal of
developing the queen set pieces
with the goal of keeping the position
more dynamic which move
comes to your mind
queen b6 is a queen b6 rook e8 okay
let's take a look at queen b6 it's an
interesting interesting option there's
queen h4 rook e8 okay so i see a lot of
i see a lot of uh attempts
you i would say you guys are close but
so far nobody hit the spot so let's take
a look at queen b6
rainbow six is an interesting decision
so you are
black is trying to attack one on b2
okay
well technically
i'm not really sure if black is black
queen is doing anything on b6 so imagine
imagine white makes a random move so i'm
just i'm just trying to prove a point
here that the queen b6 doesn't really
accomplish anything so imagine i play h3
the move doesn't change much for white
if we take on b2
what will play queen b1
right now my queen is trapped the only
square it can go back to is to a3
queens get traded and
i lose my i lose the extra pawn right
back but you see i lost it
while giving white the possibility of
making the rule extremely active because
it got to the seventh string and the
seventh rank it's taking control over a
couple of very very
important squares that my pieces would
definitely like to be on well they can't
anymore because of the rook so i would
say queen v6 is is a nice looking move
but it doesn't really accomplish much
also with your queen and v6 if you
notice you can no longer play knight c6
imagine why still plays h3 if you play
ic6 there is there is 97 which forks the
queen and the rook so queen v6 is
uh it's it's okay i'm pretty sure it's
fine but it's it's not what we're
looking for uh let's take a look at rook
e8
another suggestion
so rook e8 has a
a more defined idea we're simply just
attacking the net and e5
okay so that definitely keeps keeps
attention going
keeps a tension not attention tension
going
uh what if white plays rook to e1 so
just simple attack simple defense
nothing more nothing else i think we can
still we can still obviously opt for
knight d7 if we want to
to to keep the game
uh
kind of safe and calm
if we take on e5 actually i was
seriously considering taking 95 during
the game but i wasn't
ultimately i wasn't really a big fan of
this decision just because of um of the
weakness of my default or now the d file
gets let's open up and
white spawn is really easy really simple
eventually what we'll do some selling
this and put will start putting pressure
against my d5 phone so i eventually
opted against this idea
um
well there's only one more thing left
technically right so rook e8 is a nice
looking move but i'm not sure who who
this move favors yes both sides get the
rook gets a rook on the open file but
because white white
white's e1 rook is connected and my e8
rook isn't connected with my other rook
i think this if i ever get to trade the
rooks the trade will favor white right
because white will will get to uh to
control the e file so i wouldn't be so
sure by saying that the rook e8 benefits
me more as in my opponent
well but i do like rocky8 a lot because
it it deals with it was an issue the
issue being that's not really an issue
but it's it's an annoyance the knight on
e5 is not waiting when i get out without
offering a trade right so with this in
mind
which move have i made during the game
if it's not rook e8 there's only uh
maybe a couple more options now a6 will
net a6
knight on a6 is uh not exactly a piece i
would like to have right it's on the
edge it does have a prospect of going
somewhere to e6 but it takes time
also after knight a6 doesn't quite have
something like queen b5 mb5 looks
extremely annoying because it's uh it's
double attacking the pawns
i'm not even sure how to deal
with
with the queen b5 other than
other than take on e5 but once again by
taking an e5 i kind of accept
the fact that i'll be playing with with
a big pawn right because it was a
weakness on d5
so 96 yeah not quite yes yes mate chest
057 you got it i played f6 and this this
is definitely a a way more a very
riskier decision well because it creates
an additional weakness and and it
basically baits white into play in the
next move
right now it's it's clear that that i'm
creating myself a very big weakness on
on this diagonal and
white thought that they can take
advantage of this immediately and and
with a little bit of a calculation
my opponent
has found
this pretty strong move queen b3
right so now
the issue for me here is that if i
if i take on e5 right if it in fact if i
accept
the sacrifice
there is a series of tactical hits right
so queen takes b7 obviously not queen to
queen takes d5 because after queen takes
d5 i can block the chat with rook f7
d takes e5
and bishop c7 and this way i retain the
extra piece
as though for a couple of pawns but
still it's a material advantage
nonetheless
well white doesn't have to go for this
obviously they can start by taking on b7
first
which is a much better option right now
my rook is in trouble if if if this rook
was not in trouble i would say that my
position is just perfectly fine
but because the rook on 8 is in trouble
i
you know i have to give give some of the
material back and i think the only way
to do so obviously not knight d7 if 97
white has queen takes d5 and because now
my knight
is blocking the queen and d8 i'm going
to end up losing the bishop on d6 and as
you guys notice in this position i'm not
up anything in fact i'm down to pawns
how does that happen nobody knows but
it's a fact
sometimes sometimes you play a game and
then and then you you you get your
summoner of your tactic and then and
then by the end of the attack the queue
you suddenly realize that you're missing
a knight or you're missing a piece and
and then you wonder how did that happen
well
um
i can
avoid
i can't avoid some of the um
some of the um material losses by doing
this so in this case i'm only down a
pawn obviously white cannot take on d4
because then they get hit with a very
very uh
nice
and
simple discovery
attack
i'm not even gonna ask you guys to find
this i'm pretty sure everybody in the
chat can can see bishop takes h2 which
wins the queen but you see the issue is
that y does not have to do this white
can just yeah yeah
yes bishop takes h2 is correct right but
unfortunately y does not have to take on
on d4 instead they can just bring the
queen back to d3 and and in this case
white is going to retain the extra pawn
and it's it's
it's going to be it's not going to be
fun you know despite the fact that i do
have an extra or not an extra story
despite the fact that i do have a
passport on d4 still be being down upon
as a
you know
as a as a big disadvantage
plus this is this is technically a
middle game if this was
you know closer to an end game where my
pawn is is passed and it's very very
difficult for white to stop us and it
would be a different story but now
there's a lot of pieces in white's
position that can stop my pawn
especially the queen is already kind of
coming to v3
okay so if we go back
over here
this basically means that i cannot take
on e5 as it was a pawn well fortunately
for me
taking an i5 as a bishop
does change things so how does it change
things well let's take a look what
happened in the game
my opponent took i took on e5 y2 and b7
right these are all kind of happening by
force and in this case
i am i'm losing the rook on 8. i am not
a big fan of playing any of the knight
moves right because
any of knight c6 or n86 moves will cost
me a knight knight d7 move will cost me
opponent d5 and i'm gonna play down the
pawn which once again is not ideal i do
not want to be down material
so i i'm i'm fortunate enough to have a
move
queen d7 here
so this move is going to cost me the
rook but fortunately after white
does take the rook their queen gets
trapped
this leads into a very very interesting
materially imbalanced end game right so
i play knight c6 now white queen is
trapped
they have to
give it up for
as much as possible as as expensively as
possible and therefore they take my
other rook so if we just if we just
count raw material here we would we
would find out that white's white has
extra material right because what we
have equal amount of pawns equal amount
of white pieces however white does have
two rooks which are worth five points
each versus a queen which is worth nine
points
meaning that whites technically
materially speaking white is up
to one point of material however
what we
probably did not take into consideration
first while looking at the raw material
is
the positioning of the pieces if you
notice white's ropes are still on their
starting positions okay technically the
f1 rook isn't because it has been
castled but nevertheless it's not an
open file yet also
i'm not sure i'm not sure if you guys
know about synergy between pieces so
um
there is there is that there is a thing
called synergy between heavy and light
pieces and and queen
is known to work very well alongside
with a knife because these two pieces
supplement each other
not a queen cannot cannot move as a
knight so
when they work together they work really
well and the same thing can actually be
can actually be said about rooks and
bishops because well if you kind of
combine rook and bishop you get a queen
which means that
technically speaking
the rook the rooks are supplemented by
the bishops making them into many many
queens so in this case both sides have a
very nice peace energy
however i do have a another advantage to
my position which is a strong center
right so i have two
two strong central pawns which are ready
to go right they're ready to to be
pushed up and it's going to be very
difficult for white to stop them so let
let me show you guys what happened in
the game in this position my opponent
made a an inaccuracy
and was actually a much bigger deal so
i think my opponent still thought that
they they are
their position is superior because they
are material so they were trying to uh
create an additional advantage by
trading bonds and a queen side so what's
what my opponent's plan was is
basically keep pushing the queen side
pawns until until they get traded and
until white gets a passer on the queen
side right so white played b4
hello ghillie 88
white played b4 here
intending right
for their next move to be either b5 or
a4
uh unfortunately white has forgotten
that
moves that before create a lot of
weaknesses especially because
there is nothing in white's position to
take care of white squares
where my queen
be let's say on a4 at this point if my
queen could magically get to a4 there is
no decent wise position to get it out of
there and since white's plan is clearly
to pray to play a4 my queen being on a4
is a very big problem right so with this
in mind what do you guys think i'm what
do you guys think my next move was
if i if i know
that white's idea is to play a4
what is the right what what can i do
to try and stop it
94 perfect
perfect stuff
you're correct 94. also as oh as you as
you guys know knights in the middle are
monsters right now this night is in the
center
it's a monstrous piece nobody wants to
deal with night like
this this knight has
way too many things going on its way
so
a4 runs into knight b3 well
it's an interesting point but i feel
like
well first of all you're correct maybe
three is definitely an option i i don't
think it does i don't think it wins me
anything immediately so white can still
play rocket too this defends the bishop
i don't think i want to trade right so
because my knight can always come back
to the to d4 and be very strong in the
center while white's bishop is not
really doing as much
at this point right this point i can
just
yeah yeah if knight takes d2 rook takes
d2
i would lose a pawn on the pawn on d5
and then this would be another even
trade and yes this this end game i'm
pretty sure it's heavily favored from
uh for white because all they have to do
to win my pawn is to just simply double
up on the a file and it's going to be it
so
obviously cannot let this happen means
that they cannot accept trade offer but
what i can do is i can just
do this right and at this point it's
funny but white is paralyzed why there
is nothing wet can do to keep pushing
their pawns
if white tries to attack my pawn on a7
well it's not going to work right if
bishop e3
i can just simply play d4
so because white's pieces are so passive
when my and my pieces
i don't i don't really have that many
pieces i only have one between the
knight technically so because because of
such a drastic difference in peace
activity
despite the fact that i'm down material
right this is something that you guys
you guys saw in the previous lecture i
believe in the end of previous lecture
right with alex
black was was down material
nevertheless because of how active their
pieces were
they were they were trying to win the
games they had an advantage and this
this this
this just lives to to show you guys the
material is not everything
you should always ask yourself a
question
what are your pieces doing
if you have an extra piece it has to be
it has to be in the game it has to be
working otherwise it doesn't count
right so in this case
white's plan was to play 5d6 well it's
not gonna work right because my queen is
taking is taking care of both of the
pawns
if white pawn if a pawn moves up the b5
pawn is gone
right
well
if that's if that's how things are then
white's only plan has failed and well
i don't i think this position just
simply was provided because well i have
a very clearly defined plan i just want
to queen eventually so
uh i'm not sure maybe white can try and
stop me but it's you know when you're
defending while being up material it
says something right so something that
something has gone wrong somewhere
so this is why yeah this is why ray
realized that a4 is probably not the
best idea anymore and he played h1 but
once again we know you know the issue is
um
who is not playing a4 now a4 square
becomes available from a queen to to go
to so that's what happened i played 24
and interestingly enough raid made a
decision to to just give up his extra
material right so at this point as we
determined previously white is up one
point of material so which basically
equals to one single pawn
so just to make sure
that
his pieces can get a little bit more
activity
ray made a
very practical decision i believe
in that very very short period of time
that he he had left on his clock he
played b5 here attempting to play b6
right so this way
white is trying to open up the files for
for for his rooks
well i'm afraid i couldn't really do
anything about the b6 idea so i just
accepted
the material back
and moved into this position
so at this point
since the rooks has the rooks have
become so active
new problems arise
for me at least right because the rooks
are so powerful especially when they're
connected rooks are looks extremely
powerful and annoying
if if they both get onto the seventh
string
with something like this my king will be
in in brave danger
so i had to address the issue
immediately and i found a really really
interesting solution to the problem of
king safety here well because the king
cannot really be defended by anything on
the right side of it right so here
these three squares cannot be blocked by
any of my pieces
i thought to myself well
what if i just moved my game behind the
pawns right and by behind the pawns i
mean behind my kingside pawns and
therefore i played h6
or b1
and here i think i made a mistake i
believe so i i
at this point i thought that i can play
kj at any point
i should have done it immediately by the
way but i played queen c4 instead and at
this point there was some kind of weird
tactic i can maybe even
let me see if i can cheat a little bit
and and take a look at the engines about
it's going to screw up everything right
if you do this
not everything
it screwed up
a few things
but yeah there there is some okay there
is there's some there's some rook b7
and the idea of rp7 is this better now
let's see
i closed it it's not better is it
no
uh
okay so i see what you i see what you
meant when you said it's the the the i
mean i can fix it myself not
not a big deal
here
i go i got this
and there you go
here
here
like this
sorry guys a little bit of
a technical difficulty present here um
up a little bit better i mean it's not
as good as it used to be but it's it's
workable all right we can work with this
is it is this uh ray versus ellie yes
this this game yes this is my game
against ray from
2019 we played this during uh
a sinful spring spring invitational
tournament that's actually gonna
actually about to happen it's right
around the corner it's happening in
about three weeks in the beginning of
march and ray is playing there too so we
actually gonna get a get a chance to
play each other again
okay so
so here yeah so at this point there was
yeah there was some weird weird tactic
which which ray did not find he played
rook e7
which allowed me to play kh seven and
hide my king essentially so obviously
if if if only white's king was in g1 at
this point right if only this game was
on g1 at this point white could have
played rook b7 and they would have
gotten
a lot of counter play on the seventh
ring
but because the king is in schwann
obviously b7
fails the queen f1 checkmate
well
the issue is clear the solution
also pretty clear if white wants to play
rp7 they need to do they need to make
sure the king doesn't get checkmated how
do we do that well
simple right just h3
now i played knight d4
rook b7 well once again white doesn't
really have much to do other than try to
create some kind of counter play
otherwise
because of how strong my queen alongside
with the knight are
and
having the central pawns on top of that
would be a huge deal a huge problem for
white so rugby 7 happened i have the
only defense right so rook g7 is
is
is threatening and i need to i need to
do something about this i don't want to
i don't want to get checkmated so i need
to defend the g7
this is why i play knight f5
and f5 is is great it's it's both
attacking and defending the pawn on g7
are not leaving white was with that many
options right if white let's see plays
rook f7 here
i would play queen f1 check
king h2
and queen takes f2 so this this way i'm
now i'm officially up material if we
look at at a true a true
um
widely known values of each piece which
in my opinion is rarely a correct way of
evaluating each is the strength of each
piece on the board but anyway at this
point i'm up upon right i just i just
ate a pawn on f2 i'm attacking the
bishop on d2 i'm defining my own knight
and the f5 and now most importantly they
have two connected past pawns that do
not have they do not have any any um
any vis-a-vis
uh on any of the of any of the
adjacent and uh and end files
well
rocktakes e5 is probably the least of
the worst that ray could have done
actually at this point i believe both
queen takes f2 and knight to h4 was
winning but i decided to go for a
prettier
for a prettier option at h4 but why is
it preyerable because i'm forcing my
opponent's king
into the corner
and well because
the corner is not exactly the ideal
uh position for the for for the king to
be on especially when the queen is
present on the board i thought that i
actually have a very good chance of
of of checkmating
checkmating white's king or if the
checkmating thing doesn't work i can at
least maybe um maybe win a rook or two
right because now i'm threatening queen
d4 or queen for queen of four is
obviously i think even more scary than
queen d4
but nevertheless um it was hard to to
avoid both so so ray decided to make
sure
that both rooks stay intact uh
unfortunately at this point um the
position is it took too long
at this point any move that white makes
will avoid d4 so any move that white
makes leads to them either losing a rook
or getting checkmated so in this case if
let's say white plays h4 the king gets
completely trapped so i have the
checkmate on f3
and if the rogues move elsewhere i would
say if the rook moves anywhere on on the
e file there is checkmate on g5
and if the rook moves anywhere on the on
the fifth
fifth rank which actually did happen
i can win the rook one of the rooks by
force
can you guys find a forced a fourth way
of winning one of the rooks
i'll give you a minute
yeah yes
yeah yes centipede correct queen to
abstract check
kings force back to h4 and then queen f6
was double attack
which was the end of the game
and ray resigned
so
once again
uh
this i feel like i feel like this
lecture about judgment call
as uh is a little a little bit tricky
to
to um explain in a lot of detail
but
this is something that i really like
about i'm basically showing you guys um
uh this particular topic because
um i my favorite player is magnus
carlsen i believe this is this is
exactly
uh um
something that magnus does very well as
you guys can tell f6 is by the way not
by any by any means of the best move in
the position right the best move in this
position in the original position is
knight to d7 which keeps which keeps the
balance going but f6 leads to to
materially imbalance position
but it gives it gives your opponent a
chance to to misstep right so if um
if you're if you're playing for
or if you're trying to create some kind
of play in a very boring position that
moves like f6 is a moves like f6 are
definitely your way to go and also
you you know you you shouldn't forget
that the time
uh the time the remaining time on the
clock is also a big factor while making
such decisions so in this case rey was
once again
a little bit a little bit he had a
little bit less time than myself and
i knew that if uh if i can get
uh if i can get in the position into uh
into the unclear and imbalanced
territories that then because of
um my time time advantage i would have a
higher chance of navigating through
better than my opponent and in the first
example if you guys remember
the situation was was kind of similar
but in that case i i didn't realize that
the position that that would appear uh
in the materially imbalanced end game
where i would be down down the piece um
would also be
very very tricky to navigate
um
as as for me as much as for my opponent
so i i did not make in that case it did
not make the correct judgment call by by
by making it happen
how long am i teaching this class well
technically this is already kind of over
i mean this was this was my last example
i didn't i honestly did not expect
myself uh to go through this so quickly
but it's it's it should be about it
should be about one hour
uh what what do i think about about
ferrucci next world champion when well
well he's he's definitely an extremely
strong player and and he's been he's
been showing uh
um yeah a
great deal to improvement right he's
he's been improving non-stop for for the
past however many years and he doesn't
seem
to be stopping anytime soon that's
definitely a great thing when when
you're talking about improvements
on and a level as high as as high as
2800 right that's basically um this
place basically the the top tops three
and and for somebody to to be constantly
improving and reaching that that higher
level is definitely extremely impressive
and i do believe that ferruccia has an
excellent chance of eventually becoming
a world champion i'm not sure if he's if
he's there yet if he's ready but we'll
see um he he will have his chance to
to participate and you know to
to maybe maybe earn his way of
challenging madness and and um
and yeah i wish him the best
if he deserves it he will get it
do remember to take into consideration
other factors while you're making a
decision of which move to make and yeah
once again those factors can be can vary
from the amount of time you have versus
the amount of time your opponent has to
uh to
to the end to your end goal whether
you're trying to keep the position
simple or or come or try to make it
complicated
[Music]
you